let's go to sexual performance um is
that something that you studied have you
come across any research papers on that
a little bit um I haven't studied this
nearly as much but I I have I have a few
few notes for that as well so one is uh
you've mentioned this in a number of
your videos but uh if you can't see your
Johnson then then
that that's that's a big problem I don't
what you're G to say
yeah yeah so you get out of the shower
and you look down you can't see Johnson
you got a problem boys right yeah yeah
lose that weight so so reducing body fat
is is a huge one um mainly because
obesity and just being overweight has
tremendous effects on the your your
vasculature so we think about body fat
but honestly has a tremendous effect on
your vascular Tre as well so blood flow
can't get to the areas that it needs to
yeah um the second thing is resistance
training so while you know we talk about
testosterone for example resistance
training is an excellent source of
pumping up your testosterone as a whole
typically resistance training
individually uh when you when you do a
session your testosterone spikes and
then it comes right back down within
about 30 minutes but overall just the
the the fact that you have to put on
muscle and maintain that musculature
that ultimately has a tremendous effect
on your overall testosterone levels
which testosterone free Unbound
testosterone has tremendous effects on
like erectile dysfunction has ual or
libbido you know all that stuff so
resistance training is a huge one and
then for the people that don't want to
do either one of those obviously I don't
recommend that at all but uh the the
other one that I've read one study on
this and I I planned on doing a lot more
on this but I just haven't gotten around
to it is there's a supplement called red
Korean ginsing um which this one study
found that this was in uh I think men in
their 40s or 50s something like that and
they took red Korean ginsing and
ultimately found that they had better
sexual performance um not like massive
differences but a you know relatively
like let's say a moderate effect um also
erectile dysfunction was dramatically
reduced not completely eliminated but
certainly better um what was the pathway
that the red Korean jining uh work
through was it nitri nitric oxide or was
it something else yeah so they they had
a few different uh few different
suggestions one of them is you're
exactly right so it has effects
independent of dooster actually
increases nitric oxide which uh gets
released by the endothelial cells those
then B bind to the smooth muscle cells
within our vasculature specifically
around the penis in this situation and
then it ex it opens up the the
vasculature so that you can actually
have an erection or have have better uh
vascular flow to the brain as well um
and and then the other one that they
surmised was uh that jins sing also
binds the actual molecule that's or a
molecule I should say that's found in
jins sing also binds to what are known
as Gaba receptors so Gaba is a anxiety
uh related uh
neurotransmitter and they don't exactly
know if that is one of the main
mechanisms but they do know that it has
an effect through that so I think
there's a lot more research that needs
to be done on the topic but um you know
it's something did they did they compare
it to something like uh L Arginine and L
what's the other one carnitine I think
which are probably the most relied on
now for nitric oxide nitric oxide
boosting
properties no they didn't not not in
that study again um yeah again
unfortunately I've only looked at that
one study so it's something I need to
look into more I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out